[Music]
are you lucky enough to find yourself
with thanksgiving leftovers and you just
don't know what to do with them
thankfully we got you we're backstage in
the test kitchen
with tara bench tara what's cooking we
are doing
leftover thanksgiving mashed potato
duchess potatoes
easy easy we have about four cups mashed
potatoes here so we're going to add some
egg yolks
and then quarter cup of heavy cream some
salt
and pepper add some fresh nutmeg once
that's mixed together let's spoon it
into
a piping bag fitted with a star tip so
we go bloop
brush a little melted butter on there
that's going to help the airfryer get it
crispy
best part we get to add some rosemary
we've teamed up with lg
and we're going to use the built-in
airfry feature on our lg
insta view range and you want to know
why it's called an insta view
because you can knock twice on the glass
to see inside without having to reach
over a hot cooktop
or even turn your oven light on you cook
it at about 400 degrees
for 15 minutes we have leftover gravy
from thanksgiving
so just drizzle a little bit right over
those potatoes
oh my gosh that was so good
i couldn't stop and i want you to check
out the drewberrymarsh show.com for
our recipe duchess potatoes